[موسيقى]
تاريخ عائلي كامل لأن
هذا الماس syndicara لأن
أخبرتك أنه من الخام
ساندي كاراتس لم أستطع حتى الوصول إلى هناك
الوصول إذا لم يكن لدي والدي و
أخي الماسي الذي أفرغ لأجله
تملك هذا الماس في الخام أي
أن التعقيد يبدأ حتى
قبل تصنيع الجزء
بدأت للتو في الوصول إلى هذا
حجر خام استثنائي من 110
قيراط الذي أنجب 15 طفلاً
استثنائية ثم بعد مرة
لديك هذه الأحجار الخمسة عشر الاستثنائية
معرفة لا تصدق هو
سحر كل الحرفيين لدينا ولكن هو
أيضا سحر الخلق
نجح في تجميع 15 حجرًا له
يجعل هذه المجموعة جميلة جدًا ومدهشة إذا أ
مثل هذا التقدير الجميل للموضوع المصري
خنفساء وسوف نقول يطير
قوة قوة رمزية
الروحانية التي لدي الكثير
مستوحاة من مصر القديمة
[موسيقى]
أنا مستوحاة من مصر القديمة لأن
إنها فترة دائما معي
مفتون منذ الطفولة وفي الحقيقة أنا
اعتبر ذلك مع عودة الذهب
أصفر لا أعرف كان لدي مثل واحد
رؤية أن هذه الحضارة
كان طليعيًا جدًا نحن الذين
هي علامة تجارية تركز بشدة على
المرأة في الواقع لديها زوجاتها
ولدت كليوباترا أفيرتيتي الذي كان
حتى العالم الخارجي ما يعادل
لقد قلت لنفسي حقًا يا رجل
تسير بشكل جيد للغاية للعودة قليلاً إلى هذا المزاج
ضخم جدًا وحتى تقريبًا
طليعية من هذه الفترة
[يضحك]
موسيقى
[موسيقى]
بالنسبة لي مصر القديمة
الحبر الذي تراه جانب الأرض مع
تضيء الشمس ويحل الليل
الأبراج لذلك فعلت كل شيء
لون أزرق حول منتصف الليل إلى
مغرة مع الذهب الذهب الذي يمثل
الشمس نور الحياة
[موسيقى]